I like a good drink in the face too
that's a real clutch move I know have
you ever done that no you're missing now
do it all right will you walk me through
what happened there yes so okay well um
think about something that makes you
really really angry like you know if
your boyfriend cheated on you or um like
if a girlfriend betrayed you yeah
something like that because she was like
going after my girlfriend so I was
sticking up for my girlfriend oh yeah so
I'm a girl's girl oh yeah so just think
about something that makes you really
angry and then grab the table okay right
and hold on to it yeah and then right
now at the count of three all right
ready one one two three
I need something
[Applause]